servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir befinden uns heute
auf primitive sitze rechts denn heute
sind drei neue maps rausgekommen die ich
heute mal gerne vorstellen möchte ich
habe auf twitter gefragt ob er das cool
finden würde und die resonanz war
ziemlich positiv also machen was jetzt
schnell und wir fangen an mit dem map
pack okay leute machen also wer jetzt
einfach drei runden spielen
beziehungsweise ich spiel drei runden
ihr seht das nicht ich springe dann
immer direkt ins deathmatch und laufen
bis mit euch herum
übrigens könnt ihr einfach diesen tag
kennt ihr diese diese kinder diesen
moment ist bei euch auch so dass ihr
teilweise einfach tage hat an denen eure
haare einfach ohne näheren grund total
beschissen aussehen ihr macht das genau
wie man an einem tag habt ihr so dass
übertriebene fabulous her und am
nächsten tag ist einfach verdammt
scheiße aus heute ist so einer aber ganz
ehrlich mich juckt nicht möglich okay
leute das jump run ist durch beide male
kuck mal wer hat noch drei minuten auf
der uhr an sieht man wie viele leute da
rechts befindet haben so leute so sieht
die webos hier
das ist eine evakuierungszone weg steht
für ebay
leute ich hab mir ich hab mich jetzt mal
kurz umlegen lassen natürlich waren
alles mit absicht die habe ich nicht
getötet oder so und auch hier bisschen
besser die map von oben zeigen zu können
so sieht das aus ziemlich witzig
eigentlich im baumhaus das ist die weg
eine verlassene notfall evakuierungszone
hellblauer historie hospiz das fürchte
dich maria ich bin eine junge frau der
heilige schafft über dich kommen
deshalb wird auch das kind heinz kopp
genannt
neu ist die idee kam bestimmt auch ganz
nice dadurch matt backen wie drüben
ich weiß ja nie wirklich weiß dass ihr
sein soll
ich kann nicht mehr ich kann nicht mehr
sagen es sieht einfach falsch aus was
was soll das sein
wisst ihr was das darstellen sollte da
wir manchmal ein kleines ließ der ecke
mit herpes usd auseinander wand entdeckt
ansonsten scheint die map mir ziemlich
ziemlich groß zu sein eigentlich
ich weiß gar nicht ob die jetzt größere
maps entwickelt haben also guck mal hier
drüben
es ist doch ein sehr umfangreiches teil
alles klar
hier ist nun mal so ist wie beim sonst
so sucht das sieht auch ganz nice aus
hier unten weiter also auf web backen
kann sich auch durchaus lohnen hier denn
wir sehen da außen rum ist auch eine
ganze menge zeug dann springen wir jetzt
mal zu stronghold damit erfolgreich
töten lassen jetzt können wir über die
map drüberfliegen das sieht so aus
müssen die radisson so ein bisschen
höher stellen
das ding heißt stronghold und das soll
ein hightech chateau sein kann ich hab
euch übrigens den artikeln nähmen die
maps normal erklärt werden in der
beschreibung verlinkt hier das sind die
alpen also die man sich vorstellen dass
die schweiz gerade weil dies nicht
gesehen haben dass die schweiz die
schweiz erfahren hat und schweiz
erfahren irgendwo irgendwer irgendwie
hallo dieser wert diese treppe gebaut
wird das zu verantworten das ist nicht
wie treppen funktionieren die treppe
sollte so funktionieren sollte immerhin
für mich in die fucking decke
also ich bin hier um geflogen ich habe
keine schweizer fahne gefunden
nichtsdestotrotz sieht die ganze sache
sehr cool aus hier richtig schön im
penthouse leute eines tages hoffe ich
dass es youtube maria ausgerechnet mir
aus dem statur kaufen kann dann ist der
blick im real life nach leute kennt ihr
noch taxis kassel wo die menschen so
komische parcours durchlaufen mussten
das mache ich das der jump hat und dann
dass sie auch mit schwereren böden so
kämpfen hier in diesem in meinem
persönlichen chateau in der schweiz das
blatt den gegner kämpfen
bitte klicke meine videos damit ich das
machen kann es sind jetzt hat das ding
aber jetzt springen als letzte nummer
drei die erst frisch sowie die tv
sendung okay leute das german für die
dritte map lynch startet jetzt gerade
besitzer rechts und schaut mal intern
reimann ist es immer so immer wenn ich
auf der oft primitiven und irgendwie
bisschen länger in der lobby warten muss
weil ich eine spezielle web bestellen
wir ungefähr alle prämisse die auf
diesem server sind
nachbarn
tremblay ok fringe wird als verlassene
farm statt oder bauern stadt beschrieben
und wir bauen hier auch direkt in so
einem boden das ziemlich cool ich mag
auf jeden fall die atmosphäre dieser map
erinnert mich an die minecraft welt die
man die kleine schwester mal gespielt
hat mein bruder hat meine kleine
schwester bauernhof zu bauernhof mit auf
den pc geladen hat sie darum gespielt
daran erinnert mich das hier könnte auch
für mich zu töten so wer muss wieder
erfolgreich töten lassen jetzt schauen
wir von oben drauf sind wir sehr schön
nachgebaute bauernhof ich könnte einfach
nicht bauen wollte ich könnte so was
nicht bauen
ich bin kein bauer verstehe ja meister
farm ist was soll das sein
hat sich da einfach ein l umgedreht der
ösv die schienen gelegt ein l aus schnee
ich glaube ich glaube ja ich glaube dass
die ursache oder die soll es ein
entgleister zug
was meint ihr l aus schnee oder
entgleister zug schwierig zu sagen ich
würde fast sagen dass fringe mein
favorit von all den maps ist aber leute
ich muss mich entschuldigen hatten
gestern abend ziemlich große party und
ich hab auch die letzten nächte so wenig
geschlafen
also wenn ich im heutigen video ein
bisschen verletzt war und alles ein
bisschen komisch ist und natürlich dann
liegt es daran sowie dafür aber auf
jeden fall danke fürs zuschauen wenn
euch irgendwas an den videos stört wenn
ihr irgendwas besser machen wollen würde
schreibt das unbedingt und in die
kommentare hier ist die kommentare und
ich freue mich immer riesig über kritik
seid ruhig kritisch dürfte wirklich sein
so